what's up Wolfgang I hope you all have
seen Avengers infinity war by now and if
you haven't go to the theater right now
seriously you need to see it and also if
you haven't seen it there's some
spoilers coming to you in this video
also don't forget to enter our giveaway
for your chance to win some pretty sick
speakers all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel and join the
wolf gang subscribe to the stupendous
wave leave a like and drop a comment
below with your favorite superhero from
Marvel DC or otherwise alright if you
haven't seen them fin anywhere get ready
for the spoilers so today we're gonna be
talking about why we never saw the Hulk
after Thanos kicked his butt so in the
beginning of infinity war when Thanos
and the Black Order are on the ship that
Thor and the rest of Asgard were on we
see Loki say we have a halt and then the
Hulk attacks Thanos Hulk seems to be
doing all right hitting Thanos multiple
times but Dallas isn't really fighting
back and when he finally does he lays
the whuppin down on Hulk and if you
notice the first time that Thanos
punches the Hulk the Hulk is really
taken back and he's just really shocked
and he as he continues to fight Thanos
you can see that when he's fighting he's
kind of scared danos just came with his
black order and defeated basically the
rest of Asgard that includes Heimdall
and Thor and then the next thing you
know Daniels comes and just pops the
Hulk right in the face and continues
just to beat the crap out of them now I
know a lot of people were really upset
with this scene and the fact that the
Hulk never came out it was just Bruce
Banner the whole entire time because we
all know that the angrier the Hulk gets
the stronger he gets
and it just it didn't seem like that
happened we saw at an age of Ultron
where the Hulk is fighting the Hulk
buster Iron Man and the whole buster
Iron Man slash Tony Stark they they get
him they get Hulk really good but in the
end the whole just gets angrier and he
gets stronger and then ultimately he
essentially wins so I know a lot of
people were mad that the Hulk just kind
of laid down after fighting Thanos but I
do think that there is a pretty decent
explanation for this and although I may
not like the explanation
I'm coming up with myself many of you
probably have thought about it and you
might not like either but I think it's
that the Hulk was scared the Hulk was
terrified of Thanos the first time that
Thanos punched him he became terrified
of him so instead of being angry he was
scared so if you remember the fight
scene or if you go and see it again pay
close attention when the Hulk is
fighting Thanos after he punches him
he's not going crazy he's not thrashing
around with an angry look on his face
he's just he's getting beat up and that
terrifies him because it's really never
happened before and due to that fact
Thanos beats him with ease and knocks
him out actually and then Heimdall sends
him back to the sanctum sanctorum and
when he lands in the sanctum sanctorum
and Wong and dr. strange come up to him
he's changing back to banner but he's
still partially the Hulk and he speaks
in the Hulk voice still and he says
Stannis is coming and in that moment you
can see that the Hulk really is
terrified of just how strong fan oohs is
Mark Ruffalo himself talked about how
terrified the Hulk was of Thanos before
the movie even came out he says that he
sees what damage Thanos can cause and
how powerful he is and he falls into the
sanctum sanctorum screaming bloody
murder to try to warn everybody about
Thanos because he's that powerful now I
understand the Hulk being sort of
terrified of Thanos and not coming out
when the black order attacked Stark and
Doctor Strange and Wong in the beginning
but I think we all expected the Hulk to
come out when Banner was in the
Hulkbuster suit and it was being
overtaken by the outriders and the Russo
brothers definitely trolled us like
hardcore because they show in trailers
the Hulk running in Wakanda with some of
the Avengers and this never happened
clearly the last time we saw of the Hulk
was when he changed back into banner and
the sanctum and I know a lot of people
were pretty disappointed with how they
made the Hulk look in this film and I
kind of was as well but I can see the
point that they were trying to get
across by the Hulk not being able to
come out or being scared to come out
because Thanos is just that powerful and
we see that in the movie Thanos wins he
gets all the stones at the end and it
seems like he honestly wasn't trying
that hard by far the hardest thing that
danos had to do
the movie was not the fighting but was
sacrificing good more to get their soul
stone and I think that that's what the
Russo brothers wanted us to feel like
because Thanos in the comics is
ridiculous he kills everybody right and
that's how they wanted him to be
portrayed in the movie which I agree
I wanted Thanos to just beat the crap
out of everybody the whole entire film
which I'm glad we saw but this could
also be setting up something for the
future with the Hulk I don't want to get
anyone's hopes up and I know my man Hulk
smash wants to see this but we could
possibly be getting set up for world
breaker hulk in the comics hulk leaves
earth and ends up on another planet
that's a really long story not gonna get
into that now but on the planet he meets
a girl marries her she becomes pregnant
and eventually she dies and he believes
that the child dies as well turns out
the child didn't die again long story
not getting into it now but he believes
that the child did die and his wife in
fact did die and he goes crazy and he
attacks earth and this is where world
breaker Hulk comes in world breaker Hulk
is a beast he's a true monster and he
becomes this due to such tragedy in his
life there's going to be so much tragedy
in Avengers for half of the universe got
wiped away from existence and along with
them half of the Avengers and we know
Hawkeye is going to experience some
major tragedy and Avengers four and
become Ronan so why not have Hulk
experience some major tragedy as well
and Avengers four and become world
breaker Hulk if they're going to fight
Thanos again in Avengers four they will
a hundred percent need him and if
someone comes in like Galactus in
Avengers four or something they will a
million percent need world breaker Hulk
but this is just wishful thinking on my
end and I think a lot of people's ends I
think a lot of people would love to see
a world breaker Hulk especially since we
didn't really see the Hulk and Avengers
infinity war no I don't even like the
hokies like smash smash I prefer you
thanks but if I'm being honest when it
comes to five evil beings he is very
powerful and useful yeah banner is
powerful and useful to know and I do
think it's because Stannis J
scared the heck out of him he was too
afraid and maybe even a little
embarrassed in the shame to come back
out but here's hoping for redemption for
the Hulk in Avengers 4 so that's it for
today's video I do hope you all enjoyed
it please leave a comment below to let
me know what you thought let me know
what you think of Avengers infinity war
and what you thought about the Hulk's
brief appearance in it and about the
Hulk not showing up the rest of the
movie and just a final reminder about
our giveaway be sure to enter for your
chance to win a speaker system all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
subscribe to this stupendous wave leave
a like drop a comment below with your
favorite superhero that could be from
Marvel DC or anywhere else thank you so
much for watching
woof woof Bruce you got to work with me
[Music]